how many years were you in TV I started
well when I once I officially moved here
which was 2005 I did it for about six
years and yeah I worked on Prison Break
that was the first show and then the
last show was East bounded down in North
Carroll to North Carolina to to shoot
that film she shoot that TV show and
yeah I definitely had different
reactions on both shows season one a
prison break was really really exciting
it was the hit show and I was really
glad to be a part of it that I was
finally making money in LA and everybody
you know all my friends were calling me
and they're like oh yeah I just saw the
show last night and what's gonna happen
and you know it's really exciting and I
was really open to doing you know
whatever the producers wanted me to do
whatever my bosses wanted me to do and
it just felt great being a part of a
team and even though I wasn't involved
creatively I was like yeah this is you
know I've made it I'm gonna you know you
know maybe I'll be you know writing a
show one day and and you know I'll have
my name in the credits
but then flash-forward six years later I
was actually working on eastbound and
down in North Carolina and I loved all
the people that I worked with I really
you know I really connected with them
and you know they were great just that I
felt differently on that last show I was
really unfulfilled and there was so many
things happening and all the days we
couldn't we couldn't I was in accounting
them all the days were all the paperwork
was getting high and I didn't really
have time for my writing you know I
would always go home and fall asleep at
the computer and it would really bother
me and I thought you know how many more
years am I going to be doing this and I
remember specifically we there was a
sizzle reel of the show where they cut
together all the different I'll you know
all these highlights before the season
started
of the the show for the cast and crew
you know he get excited for the upcoming
season and I watched it and I didn't
really feel anything and I looked at
other people who didn't have anything to
do with their show creatively there my
level or in a different department they
were really excited and they were just
like you know so see they were saying
that all the stuff that they went
through was worth it because of you know
what they saw in the sizzle reel and I
just felt like you know I'm working on
someone else's show I didn't really feel
anything maybe it's time for me to get
out you know it's I've kind of lost that
you know it's kind of gotten old now
it's time for me to move on and try to
work on my own show or my own movie you
know so that's when I decided to leave
do you think the recession had anything
to do with that too because you started
when the recession when the economy was
doing fairly well and then I don't think
so because I mean nowadays there's all
these different shows you know shows are
abundant now I mean whoever says that
there's no work and Hollywood and it's
all competitive I mean they don't know
all the shows that exist that they'll
never see on all these different
platforms so I don't think I mean there
was always a show so that I don't think
that was the case for me it was just my
own personal fulfillment I wasn't
feeling it so then did you say well I'm
gonna did you give yourself any kind of
deadline you say I'm gonna leave this
job and do something that's you know
more piecemeal or part-time and then
work on my own stuff I did try to give
myself a deadline but I'm also really
bad at deadlines too I've noticed it's
one of my big weaknesses you know I
usually predict stuff like I'm gonna get
it done by this time and then you know
I'm still trying to figure that out but
I did take some you know writing classes
and and I felt like it was time for me
to you know start writing my own feature
film and I knew there's going to be a
big learning curve
that you know I was going to take some
time so I was but I was ready to do it I
was ready to to you know if you took
years you know I was gonna do it
you